[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to et live I'm Sophia
Lacey with Sadie Robertson today thanks
so much for being here so excited to see
you again so fun now Sadie's new book
live fearless is out right now
congratulations thank you so much tell
me a little bit about the title and the
inspiration for this project yeah so
live fearless automatically some of you
are probably thinking like oh that book
is not for me well if you said that it
probably is just for you because the
thing for me is my whole life like ever
since I was little I was always just
kind of a panicky person I was more
driven towards like anxiety and fear and
like my family I was like adventurer so
they're the kind of like let's go jump
out of a plane and like it why would you
do that I kind of just thought that's
like Who I am this is how I'm gonna be
whatever I was in like once I started
growing up and like opportunities
started coming and I started like not
wanting to do them because if here I
started realizing like whoa this is like
not just like I don't know something
that is a part of it this is something
that's stopping me from doing a lot of
things in my life like dance of the
stars when they asked me a lot of people
know this originally I was like no cuz I
was too afraid then my little sister was
like it's just the fear talking or it's
this Sadie talking it kind of changed
everything for me and from that moment
on I kind of realized like the
importance of living a fearless life but
what I realized and that is that it's
not that things aren't going to be scary
and it's not the opportunities aren't
going to come that are going to seem
very fearful but it's that you live a
fearless life you have strength you have
peace and you rise above you have this
hope and something greater and so that's
kind of inspiration behind the book is
that all my life I thought this is Who I
am but that's not who you are something
you deal with who you are is so much
more purpose and what fear will limit
you to do you know and you get real
about a lot of the challenges that you
faced in your life especially you talked
about Dancing with the Stars and that's
something that I think has gotten picked
up a lot since the book has come out but
I would love for you to set the record
straight for people who haven't picked
up a good luck yet so well set the
record straight on your feelings about
dancing because there are lot of
headlines out there that are like Oh
Sadie Robertson slams Dancing with the
Stars okay that kind of stuff Falls I
of Dancing with the Stars and I love my
family out there and Mark is like a
brother to me and he's the best partner
ever the the whole cast the whole crew
they're amazing and those headlines made
me so sad I think for me it was all me I
was scared to do it I was afraid of
comments I was afraid of the judges I
was afraid of what people might think of
me all these different things and I was
gripped in fear so it was a me problem
not a dinner with the stars problem it
was what I had to face during that which
was overcoming fear and to me I look
back at that season in my life and
that's where fear was conquered and I'll
always look back and say like thank
goodness that happened because I had to
grow up so much and there's three months
and but it helped me and it like made me
like walk so much more confident and so
much more stronger so yeah that is a lie
hear it from my voice right now
I love these other stories and everybody
involved and know it's funny mark text
me that night he said did you say this I
said are you kidding no agenda oh dude
you're my brother like know so I'm glad
you asked that yeah I think I read it
was something like you and Mark got torn
apart for some reason like that story
right now that's like not true at all
all right well I'm glad thank you for
setting the record straight you talk
about it caught I mean the whole book is
about conquering fear yeah and obviously
dancing starts fearful experience
dealing with anxiety stuff like that you
talk about overcoming an eating disorder
as well and is that connected to well
talk me through the timeline of that
yeah and how you kind of came over so
the timeline of that a lot of people had
tagged that to dance with the Stars but
actually once again it has nothing to do
with Dancing with the Stars has
everything to do with what I was walking
in and that season in my life and what
happened is and for many people who have
struggled with eating or body image or
anything like that they'll probably know
what this is like but when you get to a
state of what your body looks really
good for some reason or another for me
it was like I was dancing eight hours a
day of course you're gonna look good and
like that's not really always gonna be a
reality when I came away from that my
mindset was that I have to be that like
I am now not good enough because I'm not
where I was which got me to an unhealthy
place because for me the only reason to
obtain that was going down this cycle of
what not
good things and so that's whenever it
got like warped and so it wasn't Dancing
with the Stars it was me coming out of
that and having the unhealthy view of my
body and whenever you have anxiety
whenever you have fear that's gripping
you and when you also like take away any
confidence that you have of yourself
that's a really scary place to be
because it literally silences your voice
and so it was just kind of all in that
same time period but in all these things
and in that darkest time that's whenever
I started to realize these values in my
life that I will carry on forever but
the cool thing is it's like with this
book it's such a journey and a challenge
for not just like my challenges and my
journey but it's really written like for
you so I didn't want to just write a
book and be like hey guys here's how I'm
fearless like know like hey guys here is
how you can live a fearless lifestyle
and it doesn't have to do with Dancing
with the Stars or necessarily a
particular thing it literally has to do
with everybody's journey and so that's
what I want people to understand it's
not Dancing with the Stars it's the
things I was faced with in that time
which we're all faced with in life
mine just happened to be on an elevated
platform absolutely and I don't want to
harp on this too much but I do think
that the eating disorder stuff is
something that a lot of girls can relate
to and a message that I do think is
really important to share so can you
talk to me a little bit about how you
overcame that your support system and
what your relationship now with food and
working out yeah so it's actually
something that me and my friend talk
about all the time because she struggled
as well and it's actually shocking to
know how many people how many women
struggle with eating disorder or body
image issues I mean it's like 90% of
women or even more and for me that was
one of those things that really hit me
of like whoa I don't want to be a part
of that I don't want to be a part of
this generation that's just like oh okay
like this is what we're supposed to look
like this is what the media gives us so
let's just starve ourselves so let's
just over workout or whatever and for me
what it looks like in my life is I had a
I had people in my life I was allowing
to speak over like what I looked like
her I was holding too much value to the
comments of maybe people people around
me or even comments on Instagram or TV
from whatever it was of how I was like
supposed to look and I started striving
to look like that but the thing is it
was an unrealistic and very unhealthy
thing for me to do so I got
we're always thinking about I didn't eat
but I talked about food so people won't
question me you know holidays on
holidays I was always making sure my
arms were like fitting under this my
legs like it's just unhealthy that's all
you can think about and it's so
consuming of your mind and it's
unhealthy and whenever you do that you
really can't see yourself one for who
you are or do for what your purpose to
do because you're distracted about what
you're supposed to look like and that's
really sad and that's where a lot of
people find themselves so for me I had
to get rid of the like the lies I had to
get rid of the people that were talking
in my ear I had to get rid of looking at
the comments and all that stuff and
actually just cover myself with okay
Sadie who are you and I'll never forget
whenever I did that when I like got some
things out of my life and I looked in
the mirror and I just started sobbing
because I was like oh my gosh like I
don't even know who this person is
because I've been so distracted on him
what I'm supposed to look like that I
forgot what I'm purposed to do and in
that you lose your sense of purpose
that's when girls feel like they're not
worthy and that they're not good enough
and all these things because they're so
focused on what they look like
that makes sense it absolutely makes
sense now between doing the show you
know during your tours your books
everything you've lived and shared so
much of your personal life with the
world is there a point where you draw
the line and you say no this is just for
me yeah for sure and we've got this a
little bit but especially in my dating
life and now I'm there you know my
dating life was very public and most
everything in my life is very public the
flaws and all and I love that because I
love that I can speak into those things
in other people's lives and I always
want to be real and vulnerable but I do
think there's a point and like love life
or whatever that you have to establish
it for yourself first and build a firm
foundation it before you share it with
the world
and I think that was maybe part of my
problem in that time is that even
whenever I didn't I wasn't necessary
confident and my body and I was going
through this inertia I'm trying to pour
into girls like this is truth about who
you are this is what God sees in you and
I believed it for them but I just
couldn't believe it for me and so when I
step back and I started believing for
myself I can speak to that so much
stronger now because I might actually
know I've seen it possible like I can
speak don't fear live a fearless life
because now I know it's possible but
when you don't know it's hard and so
just like dating it's like you have to
build that for him
foundation so that's kind of where I
like draw the line like okay not for now
you know do you think that being so
public did take a toll on relationships
in the past um it definitely changes
things a little bit you have to consider
like okay well like everybody's kind of
involved in our relationship Harvin
everybody am for the good or the bad
they are all in it and it's so cute and
it's so fun and I love that at times and
when you're solid you're selling and
it's good but when you're not it cannot
be you know I don't think people realize
that like over the past few years I've
dated different people and never account
with it publicly I'm really glad I
didn't because it's like you get all
these hearts involved now it's like all
the 3 million people are like I ship it
ok well that ship has sailed sorry like
shoot and so it's just kind of I think
that that's kind of where I like and
like I get nervous oh how do you people
about shipping that's like a very
specific part about all that like a key
maybe I need to know about this ship
because I'm gonna all right well I see
some fan questions coming in thank you
so much guys keep them coming I'm gonna
ask as many as I can here look at that
we had a question here are you dating
anyone oh my god currently no I'm not
dating into it another question here
Sadie what is your biggest fear when it
comes to dating oh wow good question
that's a great question um I think my
biggest fear in dating man that's a
great question I think like to me like
people's hearts are so valuable and it's
so like scary to think about somebody
getting their heart broken like that is
genuinely scary and so it's like that
hesitation that even jumped in because
once you've experienced Harbor you're
like oh man what if it doesn't go and
you start to like overthink I think that
can easily be a fear that I can be
loaded of like oh no or I get like to
series too fast because I'm like you
hold it to like a high standard you know
I don't know maybe that that'll be again
fear
it's true Christopher wants to know will
we ever see another season of duck
dynasty oh goodness I don't know that
now that
that would be fun I kind of I kind of
hope it hasn't been off the air that
long no wait we need to give it a little
time you know give all the time then
we'll make a comeback or something okay
now there's a question here about bra
Eldridge's video yeah I have some
questions about that so we're gonna come
back around to that I promise you guys
in the meantime you launched your live
original boxes yes all of your social
media sold out congratulations thank you
it's like insane we that has a blew my
mind it's literally sold out and all the
US states and nine different countries
just crazy it's just like awesome I'm
excited yeah so this one I know it was
about you know doing Bible study and
leadership do you see yourself expanding
the limits of franchise and what other
themes do yes
I think live original would just
continue to grow that's kind of like my
direction of what I'm really passionate
about like when I wake up I'm like
liveries you know how can we make it
bigger how can we make it better and
that's not to just make it bigger in
numbers that's to really invest in
people's lives
I think this for me it's there's so much
purpose in it like these ello boxes like
what it's literally doing is sending a
box to equip you with how to become a
local leader in your community so like
how cool is that like you don't even
have to do anything I say yes and like
we'll give you everything you need and
like they just get to lead and the fight
girls in and I think that's cool because
I think for women I mean all over the
world it's like when you need to relearn
how to be like hospitable how to invite
people in and how to host them and then
how to like lead them and encourage them
to speak truth over them because
sisterhood has gotten a little bit far
all over like that theme of like
life-giving friends encouraging friends
speak truth of her friends so I'm
excited to see that rise I think that's
what live original is doing and will go
on tour again this fall and we're adding
more day it's 20 20 cities this year so
it's just cool to see that continue to
grow absolutely and I love that you are
so passionate about leadership and as a
young person do you know you're 20 I
want to know what you think of the March
for our lives that happened over the
weekend and all these young people
coming together and being so vocal yeah
right now I think that it's cool because
all young people and early everybody
it's like we have this opportunity right
now
really be mmm of the movement that's
happening and the change that's
happening and I think about like how I
use like read books like all these
people that used to like do these
incredible things in history and you're
like wow like that person like saved it
for their time or that person did it and
you always think like man if I was in
that situation would I do it and like
now we're in this opportunity in this
position where it's not like what I do
it's like am I going to do it and so
it's cool to see people rise up and just
do it and leave with what they're
passionate and they think it's best for
our world that's essential we're all
doing we're all doing what we think it's
best for the world yeah absolutely do
you find yourself as you know somebody
who's in the position that you are
engaged in these kind of debates you
know gun control is such a hot topic
right now do you find yourself debating
that kind of stuff not so much right now
you know I think that I haven't been
like up in the big debates I'm just
really focused on investing in people's
lives like where they're at and I think
that whenever you meet them where
they're at in their homes and in their
heart I think that then ultimately like
that helps in the debates because who
they are is influenced by I don't know
what you believe and stuff like that but
it's kind of my approach and just invest
in the girls and the homes and their
families and stuff yeah absolutely
now let's talk about your family for a
minute I got like there's always
celebrations to be had
marriage babies whatever in this what is
the latest there's so many of you now
can I kept quiet for a minute haven't we
what's happening this year everything
just you know people our families chill
like we are all just like chilling I
mean I'm in Nashville doing things that
live original and stuff but my mom and
dad they're in Louisiana me and mom and
dad to my siblings and they're speaking
and stuff like that and doing great
things my dad actually started a church
so that's awesome
they've been he's like preaching on
Sunday I didn't like go pop yeah just I
mean and they're enjoying it they love
it and then while kpop I feel living out
in the land just doing their thing and
everybody's just everybody's just kind
of taken a minute to breathe which is
just so nice because the show was so fun
but for our family it was like whoa life
change so it's nice to kind of get back
in that rhythm of like oh we live in
Louisiana this is fun we do Phil he's
been pretty active on Facebook hasn't he
oh my god yes he is a very
oh my gosh what do you think of his
videos to be honest I haven't seen a
whole of them I've seen that a few and
I'm like yep that's palpable for you I
mean he's just Papa Phil and he's gonna
be yeah yeah that was I mean he did post
one about gun debates that was pretty
interesting he had a Bible and he talked
about how that would I really talk about
the arm for God and so yeah that was it
yeah I love my grandpa he is a wise man
but he he's just funny yeah we can all
agree
so also coming up this year someone has
a 21st birthday coming up yes I do
I'm excited happy early birthday so how
are you gonna celebrate 21 oh my gosh
all my friends we've already even like
texting we I mean we're just gonna have
a fun girls night
honestly like I'll not like close
friends even friends that like don't
even live in nationally I already come
to Nashville let's just have a fun night
for me like it doesn't even matter if
you're 120 120 or whatever like I always
go all out on birthdays yeah yeah I'm
excited are you excited they're like a
drink you're excited to have at 21 now
that you're gonna be don't really know
girl I don't even know how to speak that
language I'm a wine girl myself so
that's so who are you all gonna be
celebrating with is there are there any
special people in your life that you're
really hoping to bring in the 21st
birthday with this year's been so great
cuz I've been traveling so much but it's
also I've been traveling a lot I can't
wait to just be my friends I love that
now okay I can't let you go without
asking about the Brett Eldredge yeah
every single interview
I love Brett so much and I love this
song I was so excited to see you in the
video we were talking about social media
earlier and you know how crazy it's been
for you and I interviewed Brett recently
and he said that he picked you for this
video based on your Instagram yeah yeah
and he loved your positivity and you
know you're the kind of girl that you
take home to mom talk to me about
getting together with Brett and and how
he pushed you for that ya know Brett's
amazing and that was so kind he that
shows his heart of really what he wanted
for the video he wanted just this sweet
girl and there was he was really sweet
about cuz I remember asking him I was
like well it's a country music video and
you know and sometimes they can be a
little risque my audience they're really
gonna like that and he was like no like
this is just like sweet I want it to
just be beautiful which just tell this
sweet love story of just somebody bring
in at home somebody to mama that they
would be proud of and I was like that's
so nice like we I'd love to do it and we
had the most fun that day we just goofed
off I don't know and if you know him if
you interviewed he was a goober like you
know larious is a solid dude so now that
was like started a friendship that will
hopefully last a long time we actually
ran into each other at the airport the
other day and get this this is like the
story of how light I was walking around
licking McDonald's ice cream cone with
my oak slippers because that's how I
travel and he was sitting down and like
the nicest restaurant in the airport
drinking glass of wine like I'm sorry
shows nice it was it was in Dallas yeah
and I don't like walking around like a
McDonald's I'm like my little like
exotic oh right he's like stadium like
he's like coming I'm like can I even go
in there with my McDonald's and my uggs
it was funny but now he's a great friend
and a great guy and that was super fun
yeah so you guys are still in touch yeah
yeah okay so I don't want to make this
awkward or anything but when I
interviewed him I totally was like I
think he has a crush on Sadie
no he's the best like he really is the
best guy ever everybody's been asking
this at a holiday night literally the
Internet pollutes everyone beat
everybody thanks Rene everybody thanks
for Danny
I mean he's a bet like literally and we
just had so much fun together I think
everybody was like know y'all were
really laughing like nobody really were
just like we really did have a great
time but not on there girl it's too
complicated too complicated so not
dating not dating not just I know
everybody's gonna ship it yeah every
bishop you and Brian yeah that's okay I
like it did you get to meet Edgar boogie
that's what I want yes I love yes he's
the dead la Edgar
oh look Carol she says that wasn't a no
about Brad there was a no it was a no
for now so a few more questions coming
and Kerry from facebook wants to know
you are what a role model in today's
world should be what inspires you that's
so sweet
I think for me I've just seen my
honestly my great grandma my grandma my
mom and how they live their life and
just some women that they are how they
view life with the people around them
and all that and that's always inspired
me and like seeing that in Louisiana I
like small-town picture was always so
beautiful and then like going out in the
world and like seeing how like a lot of
times like I don't know life just
happens but it gets so messy and it gets
so honestly just like mean and like hard
hearted I was like I don't want to get
like that and I want to show the world
that there's a way that you don't have
to and I feel like for me just all the
things that I've seen and the influence
that my the generations above me have
locked out and played out I'm like I
really want to fight for that and I
really want to like just really make
sure that people in my age in this
generation remember what that can be and
what that looks like and what the fruits
of the spirit are like all these things
I just want to pour that over the world
so that really does inspire me I think
just like actually saying that it's
possible to live a good life and to live
life of truth and you may be watching
this right now you're like well I'm way
far away from that and our family I
don't know
if you've seen our read our books or
anything but like we've all been through
it - it's not that hard things have
happened are things that we're really
tough haven't happened there's been a
lot of heartache in our family over the
years but it's cool to see when you
stick together and whenever you altima
Lee have this hope for the future like
what can pan out so that inspires me and
I'm like gosh I hope other people can
take heart in that and keep going yeah
absolutely last question is from Annie
from YouTube she says you are a great
singer any chance be sad is it a hot
topic lately you know we don't mess it
around a little bit maybe one day I'm
actually glad you asked that because
it's making me like be like okay I can
do it I can do yeah live fearless say
that fearless ad you can do it say your
natural though that's like a place to do
it I think that's what's happening to me
man Nashville and I'm like wait maybe I
can do this like everybody else is doing
it no but it is fun it would be awesome
so we'll see I'll just shock y'all all
well I'm just gonna like put out an
album boom our pleasure to work with you
we've talked about it yeah like it's
definitely been discussion back in all
Nashville so yeah
I'll surprise y'all just get ready just
get ready it's coming I'm ready first
girl girl all ready for it we got
certified country days I just job you
little tanks coming your way
yes please I am so excited waiting thank
you so much for being here Sadie yes wow
thank you guys so much for watching
Sadie's book live fearless is out right
now so go pick it up and we will see you
right here again on ichi live next time
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]